[Musique]
c'est une date historique quel artiste
urbain a fait le Parc des Princes il y
en a pas
c'est dans ma tête depuis 2019 je vais
le faire
ça me pèse en fait toujours faire
attention à tout bah déjà je pense que
ça ferait une bonne intro
dadju c'est un des piliers de
la misère
[Applaudissements]
mais ce côté R&B français avec les mots
de l'urbain à un moment tu es passé par
dadju il fait de la bonne musique
[Musique]
de tous les artistes que j'ai la chance
de côtoyer cette musique là est
aujourd'hui la variété d'une génération
il a toujours voulu me faire des guerres
pires du trône c'est ce qui me motive
encore j'ai commencé je me trouvais pas
fort vraiment pas fort moi je les ai
écrit trop mal c'est pourri et revenir à
chaque fois alors c'est de la merde
ça pue la merde
[Musique]
on s'est rencontré dans un train ça a
continué puis un an après on s'est marié
et quand mon fils naît on l'entend pas
pleurer ça va bien se passer quand je
parle de ces choses là ça me fait des
effets bizarres lui il a mis une vie à
200 à l'heure
de divorcer en fait
pour la première fois mon taf commençait
à me dégoûter
[Applaudissements]
au final quand tu rentres dans le ring
tout seul
[Musique]
je sais pas de quoi demain sera fait
parce que je sais
que ça va bien se passer
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
tout ce que j'ai fait toute ma vie
c'est comme si j'avais fait tout ça
pour ça tout ce que j'avais vécu tout ce
que j'ai enduré tout ce que j'ai réussi
ou échoué c'est comme si tout ça ça
avait été fait pour que je sois prêt
pour le Parc des Princes
en fait il y avait que ça en fait marre
des Princes par des Princes par des
Princes
c'était vraiment une obsession en fait
des Princes impressionnants c'est un
stade mythique nous on a grandi avec ça
on va de
qui a joué au Parc des Princes Johnny
Hallyday Michael Jackson c'est la
consécration
c'est le premier artiste
urbain qui monte sur le Parc des Princes
donc c'est quelque chose d'historique
quand on monte sur scène la pression
elle est tellement lourde quand il y a
50 000 personnes qui sautent en même
temps le sol est tremble à ce moment là
[Musique]
je connais toute la ville tous les gens
de ma génération
je m'entends bien avec tout le monde
[Musique]
j'ai eu un bon entourage
j'ai grandi avec des bonnes personnes
j'ai des cousins à moi qui sont venus du
bled aussi
il vivait avec moi à Romainville dans
notre petit appartement
on était trop dans cette maison en fait
10 11
je comprends pas comment on est arrivé à
tous dormir là-bas
on dirait une maison magique
[Musique]
on a une fratrie de 13 frère et sœur on
est très au total en comptant tous les
enfants de mon père mais de ma mère j'ai
que d'autres
mais je fais vraiment pas de différence
avec les autres même si c'est des
demi-frères on se dit même plus hein
entre nous même si il y en a qui sont en
Afrique d'autres qui sont là en France
etc il y a pas vraiment de différence
[Musique]
c'est vrai qu'on a été tout petit on
était tous réunis dadju il venait
souvent à la maison et on allait souvent
chez lui
on lit avec mes frères et sœurs c'était
mon père quand il est parti ça il est
parti avec ce lien justement elle est
partie avec ce lien qui qui nous
réunissait tout s'est arrêté à partir du
moment où on a commencé à énormément
déménager on se voyait plus
psychologiquement c'était vraiment le
chaos un peu dans la tête
il y a quelque chose qui s'est cassé à
ce moment-là on était jeune il y avait
pas encore les réseaux sociaux les
téléphones etc ça veut dire que c'était
compliqué pour garder le lien et ça a
créé une dispersion pendant que
mon père était plus là Gims il voyait
plus la légitimité de
venir chez ma mère
[Musique]
j'étais avec son père Gims venait à la
maison ils avaient lié un lien il venait
des week-ends
mais du jour au lendemain
est parti il a fait sa vie de son côté
il s'est passé peut-être deux trois ans
mais après les retrouvailles se sont
faites au moment où on a appris que
finalement Gandhi il s'était lancé dans
la musique
on était un peu dispersés partout
et un jour il y a un pote à moi qui
vient me montrer une vidéo sur Facebook
des rappeurs de Paris deux mecs en train
de quitter
et là je vois Gandhi et je leur dis mais
c'est mon frère qui est là
tout le monde me dira qu'est-ce que tu
me racontes
[Musique]
et quelques semaines après je reçois un
appel c'est Gandhi
je dis ouais j'ai bien ou quoi il me dit
bien et toi ça fait longtemps je suis en
train de tourner un clip là viens et
vas-y kims viens on leur dit sur ce mort
ce qu'ils savent déjà une histoire vraie
sans passer par le sommaire là où les
personnages sont appelés Carlos
etc pourtant on se voit la mosquée avec
des visages mesquines
je vais dire une vérité des frères en
encombre très peu donc
n'hésite pas tu me sers la main je la
tienne touche pas ma race elle se
mariera avec un noir en particulier
quelqu'un de Mara mais moi c'est là que
ça me bloque c'est là que ça me choque
là que ça me gonfle c'est là que
j'arrête on partage pas la même
charrette on s'est vu naviguer dans
cette de guerre on voulait nous
sommes les passes Navigo il était
vraiment bienveillant avec moi
et retirer 20 €, il me donnait 10 €.
c'était un truc de fou pour moi il y a
jamais personne qui faisait ça pour moi
à part ma mère et que ma mère qui
faisait ça et lui m'a pris avec lui il
m'a présenté à la section d'assaut
[Musique]
j'ai commencé la musique vraiment par
accident
sans prise de tête en accompagnant mon
frère au studio
alors il m'a proposé de faire un son
avec lui à son qu'on a jamais sorti
d'ailleurs et tout le monde avait kiffé
tout le monde m'avait dit tu as du
talent il y a un truc à faire
[Musique]
à force d'aller au studio avec lui une
fois deux fois trois fois elle est
toujours avoir un couple après comme ça
tu sais que si ça part en freestyle tu
peux dégainer
j'ai vu qu'on allait chez Gims on a
montré mec la section à l'époque de
faire du milieu renouveau l'écrasement
de tête etc j'ai vu dans ses yeux
comme il a regardé comment il les
imitait comment on essayait de comment
en fait ma
vie en vrai
il a resté son petit micro en fait
c'était c'était mediculeux
ça me retourner
j'ai découvert le studio c'était chez
mon grand frère Sati
la section allez là-bas pour enregistrer
tout a commencé dans le 18e tout
simplement la rue Mira
la rue la plus dangereuse de Paris dadju
une fois il est venu chez moi
il m'a dit Satie écoute il faut que
j'apprenne à chanter j'ai repéré tout de
suite que le petit il allait devenir
quelqu'un de merveilleux honnêtement
quand j'ai commencé à aller au studio
j'aimais pas ce que je faisais j'avais
vraiment pas confiance en moi que je
n'aime pas ma voix j'aime pas ça mais
j'aimais trop le studio normalement
j'aurais dû arrêter si tu aimes pas ta
voix tu arrêtes tu vois mais j'aimais
trop faire du studio j'aime trop la
création
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
on fait pas ça dadju
de les travers de fou et il a posé la
casquette il est en rouge max
c'est le flanc ancienne quand j'ai capté
je pense que c'est un entraînement pour
lui aussi en vrai voilà la détermination
après il a dû être des terres ceux qui
chantait ce style là il y avait pas
beaucoup
dans les endroits comme section d'assaut
les mots qui viennent en freestyle
c'est le soir tu me fais chier même pas
30 % pour tout vous dire je suis pas à
fond non dis wallah
ça va faire un mal ça va faire les gros
tigres c'est le troisième prototype ça
t'a fait part robotique comme les photos
du public
garçon ton flopée le 75 ans personne
évidemment que l'ennemi on passe en
perso demande une paire de pompes dans
lesquelles je me sens serré
un succès monstre c'était pas un petit
succès juste à côté de toi
[Musique]
et là tu commences à dire en vérité moi
aussi comment ça va venir régulièrement
voir Gims venir voir au studio ce qu'on
sait tout ça et à la fin des séances je
l'entendais rechanter les sons c'est là
qu'ils ont entendu que j'avais une belle
voix
d'après eux et après ça ils ont commencé
à me sauter surtout baraque chanter
qu'il a fait une voix à chaque fois mais
fais un truc essaie
[Musique]
sans monter
je vous présente Alassane Alassane un
des membres fondateurs un des membres de
la base un gars qui est là depuis les
débuts de Sexion d'Assaut il m'a vu
comment c'est le premier freestyle la
wati boutique il était là c'est lui qui
me forçait à freestyler il me disait
freestyle freestyle
à chaque fois que je venais à la
boutique il mettait un bonnet qui lui
allait pas trop et
en vrai la première fois je le vois
c'est sur internet en vrai je vois sur
internet je le vois dans un
freestyle qu'il avait fait à la wati
boutique
[Musique]
jamais en bas pour finir la rue j'ai
géré la boutique de la section d'assaut
à l'époque c'était là où on se retrouve
tous très souvent
et quand dadju finissait les cours et
passer souvent me voir là-bas je le
voyais faire des textes devant des
clientes et je voyais comment elle
réagissait elles avaient la main sur le
coeur
en plus le texte il était bien maigri
donc à partir de ce moment là j'étais un
le petit il a quelque chose
et j'ai commencé à l'envoyer en studio
ma priorité c'était d'aller taffer au
McDo d'aller faire mes trucs à droite à
gauche
quand il y a du temps je vais au studio
[Musique]
j'allais au studio tard mes nuits une
heure du matin jusqu'à 6h 7h du matin et
après je retournais ta famille à midi
c'est celui qui fait le plus foutu de ma
gueule vraiment vraiment il m'a toujours
dit c'est nul ça pue la merde
c'est pourri je savais que c'était un
compétiteur je le voyais dans ses yeux
et je le titille à chaque fois c'est de
la merde ce que tu fais et tout et
revenir à chaque fois alors c'est de la
merde ça pue la merde
[Musique]
c'est de savoir freestyle
donc il y avait plein de
le mot d'ordre c'est aujourd'hui tout le
monde va frissonner j'étais pas prêt
[Musique]
et moi je commence et tout
j'ai le son dans mes veines de ma voix
viendra du Congo je commence comme ça tu
vois
[Musique]
elle tremblait je t'ai pas bien tu vois
je bougeais dans tous les sens j'ai le
son dans mes veines de ma foi
[Musique]
je te dis j'ai merdé le freestyle
j'ai merdé écoute moi j'ai merdé gros
[Musique]
quand on a fini on est descendu ils se
sont foutus de ma gueule tu as 2
millions d'auditeurs voire quatre qui
t'écoutent et il le sait et à ce
moment-là ça lui met la pression et
ouais mon pote là on est on est en Ligue
1 en fait
[Musique]
et comment j'avais la haine ou Alexa
pour rien j'étais en cours ça m'appelle
à 15h ouais allô baby
et ça raccroche
un deux trois
[Rires]
balles
je me suis toujours dit qu'il fallait
que je rattrape comme ils ont commencé
la musique ils avaient 14 ans 15 ans
[Musique]
ils ont 6 ans d'avance sur moi
donc j'allais au studio 3-4 fois plus
que tout le monde il a accumulé plus de
1100 un truc dans le genre studio ils
étaient sont tous les jours il écrivait
tous les jours tu as tout dur dadju
quelque part dans le studio pas
forcément pour chanter mais juste pour
s'imprégner pour apprendre il est tout
le temps là tu vois il est omniprésent
tout le temps là d'ailleurs l'un des
premiers gros featuring de dadju c'est
parce qu'il est dans les parages
voilà il y a un homme qu'on présente
plus
le big black
et c'est le premier qui m'a placé sur un
budget aussi big Alice
ça c'est ma vie privée
et donc black aimait beaucoup mes
mélodies qui m'a beaucoup encouragé m'a
beaucoup aidé beaucoup soutenu dans ma
carrière et donc il me dit ouais voilà
il faut que je fasse un son avec avec
Big Ali et tout vas-y viens fais quelque
chose
[Musique]
on sort pour moi voilà c'est tranquille
ne sont pas sans radio ne sont pas à la
radio pendant que je suis au McDo moi
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
mais vu que personne ne se doute que
chante mais le son passe tout le monde
chante tout le monde danse et tout et
moi je suis au frites
puis après tu vois il y a ton petit ego
de Darty qui dit mais c'est moi là vous
savez que c'est moi là arrête c'est ça
jusqu'à quand le clip est sorti on voit
que c'est moi et on me demande mais
qu'est-ce tu fais là parce qu'en fait
pour les gens si tu passes à la télé tu
passes à la radio mais tu es riche
comment tu peux être et au frites et à
la télé
c'était vraiment une surprise pour nous
parce que ça a été quand même un gros
succès pour cette époque là même lui il
s'attendait pas
[Musique]
non on veut pas d'histoire
fais tout j'ai cru ce soir à la télé
[Musique]
je voulais pas qu'il fasse est devenu
comme une fierté j'avais l'impression
d'avoir réussi quelque chose de bien
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
hybride il y avait pas ça en France
j'avais jamais entendu une voix comme ça
ou un flow une approche comme ça tu vois
ça qui m'avait marqué chez lui
franchement j'étais fan dès le début
j'étais fan de ce qu'il faisait tu vois
je trouvais qu'il avait en plus en étant
le frère de Gims il était pas du tout
enfin pour moi à l'oreille il était pas
du tout dans sa lignée tu vois c'était
pas un copicab de de son grand rêve moi
quand j'ai commencé je me trouvais pas
fort vraiment vraiment pas fort
j'ai fait quelques trucs en solo mais je
suis vite allé en groupe avec quelqu'un
en plus qui était trop fort
garde la chouette tu penses refaire le
monde sous l'effet du Taga
des petites mélodies c'est vrai qu'à mon
avis il y avait des fois où vous devez
être très stressé surtout quand tout
l'entourage fait que du rap mort
avant que je rencontre dadju moi j'étais
j'étais à la fac j'en ai souvent bosser
et préparer mes parcelles à la
bibliothèque de Boubou du coup je
passais souvent la wati boutique et
c'est comme ça que j'ai j'ai rencontré
dadju un soir on était enfin il était à
la boutique avec je crois qu'il y avait
h magnum ah je suis demande à tal quel
âge il a tal et lui donne son âge et il
se trouve qu'il a le même âge que dadju
et il faisait aussi même la même taille
à cette époque là et c'était grand HD
mais les gars on dirait un duo j'ai dit
mais attends vérité j'ai une vision
j'aime bien faire mon chaman à deux
balles tu vois je prends les deux je dis
ça y est vous deux vous êtes un groupe
vous êtes percer ensemble
[Musique]
je vais te montrer comment faire des
refrains en AirPlay replay t'as pas tout
capté la chanterai pas c'est sur ton
terrain que je t'explose quelle impoli
à l'époque j'étais incarcéré j'étais à
la maison d'arrêt de Fresnes et je
reçois un coup de fil un coup de fil de
S.pri noir qui m'appelle qui me dit
ouais dehors ça bouge il y a beaucoup de
choses qui se passent nous ça avance de
notre côté on attend que tu sors et de
là il me dit abouta le je demande de
cnews il me dit ah il va bien
d'ailleurs il a formé un groupe avec
dadju
ce qui dadju
ça fait chaud regarde à je suis ce jeune
Bambola dans Paris
j'ai connu la race venez de m'en veux
que le feu qui soit propre ou je
le ferai loin
se déplace
ils sont à la même équipe ton Rapin
spectacle lamentable on les entasse
n'hésite pas à parier sur tal il est
Pancar c'est que l'argent n'a pas
l'odeur c'est une posé dans la teuf tu
me sens mais tu ne me faut pas j'ignore
tes affines de phare je suis
inaccessible
le mec il a appelé dadju le frère de
Gims alors oui le frère de Game et dadju
ça l'avait un peu saoulé et tout il
explique à Gims c'est le jour là il nous
a bien réunis nous a dit en fait les
gars je vous dire la vérité
vous n'allez jamais percer ça n'a jamais
existé le frère d'eux qui perce Gims
première
[Rires]
franchement ce serait mentir si je
disais que j'étais totalement persuadé
de sa réussite il a beaucoup travaillé
des mois des années ça prenait toujours
pas et voilà je me suis dit c'est
peut-être pas écrit pour lui c'est tout
quand j'ai appris qu'il avait eu son bac
et tout j'étais super content pour moi
le bac c'était quelque chose
d'y pensais même pas c'était tellement
loin
et je me suis dit il va faire quelque
chose de sa vie c'est le chemin à
prendre quoi et que la voix des artistes
entre guillemets c'est toujours un peu
plein de mystère je suis passé par là
j'ai vu à quel point
les gens pouvaient être ma cavernique
manipulateur et je me suis dit oui
peut-être qu'il va se gâcher qui va
perdre du temps qui va qui va tourner en
rond
j'étais pas le premier de la classe
mais j'étais dans les dans les 10
premiers
je te disais
j'avais pas vraiment de problème à
l'école c'est juste que j'avais un
problème avec le fait de rester assis et
d'écouter
j'étais trop dissipé mais dès que ma
mère a dit je vais t'envoyer au bled
là j'ai la moyenne tout de suite
[Musique]
planète
sons ensemble là on a sélectionné 10
titres mais sinon il y en a beaucoup
plus il y en a beaucoup plus
pour moi il allait faire une expérience
c'était un délire avec nous avec avec
moi et la section mais qu'à côté il a
l'air prendre ses esprits et revenir à
la à la vraie vie et je le vois en train
de s'enfoncer de plus en plus avec Shin
Sekai avec des contrats avec des idées
donc je me dis que ça devient vraiment
son métier et
là je commence vraiment à m'inquiéter
pour d'autres
le temps qui passe n'effacera pas tous
les souvenirs que tu gardes mes erreurs
mais c'est Gims il est comme ça
[Musique]
je suis déjà là
je ne pense pas que tu y arriveras
je deviens un méchant il est dur donc
quand dadju a du succès et que ça marche
vraiment begins
certains pensent que talent ne se
travaille pas c'est dans les gènes si tu
vois la vie en rose tu abuses des
hallucinogènes mais il y a trop mis tout
sur terre ça devient facile d'être du
père l'homme que tu ne vois qu'une fois
par an et si c'est possible d'être ton
vrai père je dis la peinture
j'aurais bientôt dans les boxs
[Musique]
très rapidement il y avait une bonne
cohésion on avait surtout le même la
même temps quoi on avait la même taille
il était passionné j'étais passionné
c'était plus de l'amusement que que du
travail tu vois c'était pas c'était pas
mis dans notre tête de chiffres ou de
d'objectif on allait avec section
d'assaut
on faisait les premières parties des
énigmes etc
et après on rentre en métro on peut voir
à la télé on peut entendre en radio mais
c'est pas encore ton métier tu ne vis
pas encore de ça donc la réalité veut
que tu retournes ta fait donc dadju
servait des des Happy Meal ça s'appelle
la réalité et quand même le petit frère
de Gims quand tu arrives dans le rap et
que tu es le petit frère d'eux c'est
compliqué de mettre son empreinte parce
qu'il y a toute une lumière derrière toi
tu as trop brillé avant toi
[Musique]
si dur d'être le petit frère d'une star
mais alors d'une super star
c'est un cauchemar
il y a rien que tu fais
qui ne lui est pas attribué
ça veut dire que pendant plusieurs
années les gens savaient pas comment je
m'appelais dans la rue c'était que
[Musique]
des trucs comme ça et comme je faisais
tout comme Gims
casquette Wati B de travers comme lui
t-shirt Wati B et tout mais en fait
j'étais vraiment un mini Gims en fait
c'est encore plus difficile de percer
quand entre guillemets qui est le second
couteau
il commençait à faire des émissions
radio t'aimer ce qui était dingue c'est
que on l'appelait parfois Games parfois
le frère de Gims ils écrivait jamais
dadju et je me souviens que c'était très
compliqué pour lui ça il fallait
absolument retirer cette étiquette et
mettre la bonne étiquette qui est je
suis dadju et Gims après son premier
album il a arrêté
quand il a dit je me tire c'est vraiment
tiré
[Musique]
parfois je sens mon cœur qui
mais plus rien ne m'attriste
partir loin d'ici et moi qui faisait
tout comme Gims
bah il y avait plus Gims maintenant
donc fallait que je fasse comme moi j'ai
envie de faire
[Musique]
arrête allez on coupe la caméra
de faire tu as vu je suis pas satisfait
de ce que je fais je lui dis pourquoi et
à l'époque ça marchait il passe en radio
avec Shin sekaï il me dit ouais j'ai
l'impression que mes potes ils aiment
pas ce que ce que je fais
tous ces rêves prisés
cette changer je dis peut-être que c'est
les thèmes peut-être que c'est le style
musical peut-être que c'est je sais pas
la façon les mots que tu utilises je
n'étais pas là
[Musique]
là
et d'un devoir pour moi donc il a décidé
de changer de style musical
pour ceux qui tend les brûle sourire
laisse-moi il a changé ses mous il a
changé sa façon de chanter
[Musique]
son truc il avait son truc à lui c'est
un mélange de des mecs arène be des
années 2000 que j'écoutais chanter ces
influences là chanter l'influence
congolaise il a commencé à faire
d'autres styles de son d'autres
thématiques
et là on a commencé à se dire je crois
que tu es vraiment en train de te
trouver il arrivait en stade où il
faisait tellement de son que aboutal
s'est remis en question
[Musique]
c'est pas sur mes épaules
suis-je encore que pour
genoux et je vais voir à Boutan il me
dit la vérité
pour être honnête c'est dur je finis
qu'est-ce qui est dur il me dit ben j'ai
l'impression d'être nul
et pourquoi parce que à vous c'était
quelqu'un aussi qui est un très gros
rappeur et tout le monde lui disait tout
le temps mais l'air changé
[Musique]
on était en train de passer du rap
au champ
et au début d'adieu il avait des lacunes
dans le rap donc ça aboutal qui était on
va dire en avant dans le groupe c'était
la star au début de Shin sekaï mais la
tendance est inversée et ça abouta je
pense qu'il a il a vécu durement j'ai
commencé par le genre c'est juste que
quand tu es jeune et tout est petit et
tout tu dis je vais pas chanter pour les
meufs chanter tout moi j'étais à la cité
en fait et quand tu es en freestyle tu
vas pas venir avec un flot R&B etc donc
j'ai abandonné le champ
qui était ma base parce que c'est ce que
j'écoutais les chants religieux la
variété le rnb américain que j'écoutais
depuis longtemps que moi j'écoutais du
rap très tard
des jouets c'est compliqué je suis
insolent peut-être le confirmer on est
premier reste en retrait ne viens pas te
demander je t'expliquer
faut m'excuser
[Musique]
moi demain et ils ont fait l'album
indéfini mais quand ils ont fait l'album
indéfini il y a eu le morceau m mois de
main qui a été fait avec gradur
laisse-moi faire les choses
[Musique]
nous de c'est fini laisse-moi faire une
pause
quand j'aime bien un artiste j'aime bien
faire vraiment un bon son moment vous
voyez plusieurs plusieurs et quand
vraiment je suis tombé sur cette top là
il me dit c'était vraiment incroyable je
dirais c'est celui-là on y va
[Musique]
très très bien marché
et après le jour du clip il a commencé à
me faire écouter aussi des sons et je
disais franchement je pense que le jour
où tu vas partir en solo tu vas tout
tuer
[Musique]
à partir de la sortie de ce single tout
le monde savait que dadju
ah les personnes en solo mais pour en
parler pour parler de cette période de
de vraiment la fin de Shin Seka
chanter déjà tu vois que il était
distant et chanter directement que son
comportement il avait changé et que
c'était plus comme avant tu vois tout
simplement et du coup voilà je sentais
il faisait déjà c'est son solo alors que
on était dans un dans un dans un truc où
on défendait un projet tu vois ce que
veut dire qui était comment tu vois et
on a dadju qui maîtrise de mieux en
mieux son karaté qui commence à à
chanter de plus en plus même s'il le
faisait déjà et ça prend de plus en plus
en fait ça prend de plus en plus mais
plus ça prend aussi et plus on voit que
dadju il a
[Musique]
c'est toujours dur quand on groupe quand
tu vois le leader partir et je pense que
à ce moment aboutal s'est senti
abandonner
[Musique]
et donc de là d'adjou est rentré dans la
construction de son album il disait rien
juste il faisait du son
il a envoyé un son
300 4 5 600 et au bout d'un moment je
dis mais dadju là tu es en train de
faire un album
je vais juste au studio non non je vais
juste au studio
pendant que j'étais en train de poser au
studio c'est la gestion qui me dit ça
c'est pas tard
[Musique]
on se connaissait même pas deux fois
mais il a juste voulu me parler comme ça
vas-y franchement c'est bien ce que tu
fais
[Musique]
et tu comptes percer
de faire les choses doucement et tout et
puis ça se passe bien
il m'a dit ah ouais parce que Persée ça
va être chaud frérot la foudre fera pas
deux fois au même endroit
mon frère il a déjà percé et toi
c'est quoi
la foudre fera pas deux fois au même
endroit c'est ça que tu me dis ça le
bâtard pendant que je suis en train
d'enregistrer dans ton studio où je mets
des 10 rollers tu veux que je te rentre
tout de suite ou quoi
moi je veux faire un album solo
et là je suis allé voir Dawala
je lui ai dit d'avoir regarde je connais
pas de producteur j'ai même pas d'argent
pour me produire moi-même
je veux que tu me produise juste à une
condition je veux pas être timide
[Musique]
je le relance une fois me relance deux
fois trois fois pas de news
là je leur parle je leur dis les gars si
vous m'aidez pas je vais le faire tout
seul
elle aime répondre quoi en souriant mais
tu es sous ton contrat en fait
[Musique]